c'est vrai j'ai dit ça me laisse faire
il fallait que je le fasse
ouais bien sûr comment ça va si notre
amérique alba va très bien alors nous
avons notre traductrice habituel chez
scholes belinda
oh
bonsoir bonsoir faut savoir lâcher votre
meilleur j'aimerais vous dire merci
voilà que d'être largué je suis ravi
d'être ici de principe à cette élection
et c'est vraiment écrire de vous
rencontrer
non non la différence à l'entrée à
l'américaine
maintenant vous travaillez sous le nom
de gi taquet votre vrai nom en fait vite
à nielsen c'est correct
vous êtes né au donneur est très belle
et à l'âge de 17 ans vous devenez
mannequin quand vous étiez petit étiez
très grande un peu trop grande
et quand il y avait le jeu de qui
embrasse qui quand il veut le jeu de
quilles embrasse qui aucun garçon ne
voulez vous embrasser c'est seulement
vers l'emv essayer ce soir je vais
commencer avec vous
[Applaudissements]
mais si je suis un coup moi ça marche
pour moi très bien mon petit très bien
continue tous les deux ou quatre mille
ou 4000 ou pire hier donc au début et
sous sérieux sinon ça fait pas d'acteur
c'est ce qu'à dieu
vous savez il n'est pas marié en plus
faut y aller en fait j'aime bien celui
qui est en face
ce soir personne mais marié bien leurs
débuts vous avez la vocation de la
musique parce que dès l'âge de 5 ans
vous chanter dans la chorale de l'église
à vous êtes doué pour la flûte quand
vous n'êtes pas ça dépend ce qu'on veut
dire vous épousez vous épousez gaspard
donc
vous avez un fils avec lui et vous le
laisser se casse par votre premier mari
voulu laisser l'enfant de fuir au
passage pour aller faire un film avec
avec arnold schwarzenegger
quad à mon dieu non je vais vous tuer un
jour eh bien pourquoi
à moins de massa elle veut être cotée
hahaha
à ses débuts
m
j'explique premier film donc avec arnold
schwarznegger dino de laurentiis vous
voir en couverture de photo magazine et
il vous trouve sublime et il dit voilà
vous êtes mannequin faut devenir
est-ce que je suis pas super bien j'ai
dit bon voilà je comprends dires de
l'artiste en même temps et alors là vous
partez aux usa et
dans un hôtel à new york et là vous
faites passer alors à prêcheur sénégal
ont fait passer un petit mot sylvester
stallone en mettant mon nom mon nom et
birgit ici j'aimerais vraiment vous
rencontrer à lille va carrément voici
mon numéro de téléphone said newey est
vrai que j'ai une vision de simon numéro
de téléphone est en fait qu il faut dire
faut dire la vérité peut dire la vérité
quand vous étiez petit
vous aviez vu rocky numéro un merci et
quand vous avez vu rocky quand j'étais
petit voyez rocky numéro un avec votre
papa et vous tomber amoureuse très
jeunes de sylvester stallone
jeudi c'est simplement que j'ai envoyé
deux lettres j'ai dit je suis dit ah je
viens de finir mon premier film voilà
qui je suis je ne veux pas votre
autographes mais je voudrais vous si
vous êtes intéressé passez moi un petit
coup de fil des matches ça va et voilà
alors il vous appelle
vous appelle vous vous retrouvez au bar
de l'hôtel et vous dîné ensemble we want
miles en fait on a eu je vais remettre
mais je n'ai rien senti comme ça c'est
très los angeles
et alors ensuite évidemment vous allez à
los angeles où vous tournez vous jouez
dans rocky iv vous tournez dans cobra et
à ce moment là
sylvester stallone divorce de sa femme
il la laisse sa femme avec ses enfants
pour vivre avec vous vous les ou funky
ménage louis tu m'as fait cette trame
louis mais j'avais déjà fait bien donc
stallone stallone à ce moment-là quitte
la mère de ses enfants sacha pour ce
pour vivre avec vous ils tombent très
amoureux de vous sylvester stallone ddea
non vous savez ce qu'il a dit il a dit
en parlant de vous un il a dit elle a du
coeur
elle a de l'humour elle est capable de
prouesses athlétiques
elle a un instinct maternel formidable
alors vous venez d'en d'abandonner votre
fils julian avec son père caspar mais
bon il dit elle a un instinct maternel
formidable où tu es vraiment un service
après le combat contre la foule aux cris
de ils sont
la famille il ya défi de leader et loana
thierry maintenant je suis pas du tout
intéressé parce que vous dites je parle
pas le français je comprends pas de
lancer je peux vous dire une chose je
suis pas venu ici pour entendre cette
merde hein donc voilà donc il dit que
vous aimez la famille d'une façon
traditionnelle
évidemment il va déchanter puisque deux
ans après deux ans après vous divorcez
et la mère de stallone sais pas si c'est
vrai vous à nous dire si c'est vrai la
mère de sylvester stallone dit vous avez
retrouvé au lit avec votre secrétaire
particulière kelly c'est vrai ou c'est
pas vrai dès que je puisse vous dire à
tous soyez français italiens danois ou
quel que soit votre origine suffit de
regarder un petit peu mon cas c'est
parce que j'aime les hommes 1 et elle le
sexe mais j'adore les femmes j'adore la
beauté des femmes même et j'en suis sûr
une femme qui adore les hommes c'est
tout mais je suis également une personne
généreuse et je m'occupe des gens comme
juste maintenant quand même ma mère je
m'en occupe
et on arrête un
sylvester stallone a déclaré à la suite
de son mariage avec guy ritchie tseng a
déclaré j'ai commis trois erreurs dans
la vie vous c'est une c'est fatima lui
il a dit j'ai commis trois erreurs dans
ma vie birgit nilsson birgit nilsson
birgit nilsson et le divorce lui a coûté
70 millions 70 millions de guittet qui
te guette targit et le divorce a coûté
70 millions de dollars voilà alors quoi
quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi
quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi quoi
ok connaître alors après vous devenez
animatrice chez berlusconi comme amanda
vie et adriana voilà elle a un souffle
attendez j'ai l'oreille est vrai
j'enlève l'oreillette j'aurais glorieux
j'ai joué je me sentir sociaux
cette intrigue c'est gagné c'est ok
alors
je me sens si bien
tout le monde a bien suivi
oui il ya eu 15 par il ya eu sylvester
stallone
vous travaillez
ok
bon alors en 81 enfin bon on va papa
1,18 de linda et leur livret put sur dix
ne savais même pas jouer avec ce truc
elle a une réputation de croqueuse
d'hommes dit lui avoir aujourd'hui vous
êtes mariés
non non vous entend maintenant vous êtes
marié jette marier avec un homme qui est
un pilote automobile qui s'appellera ou
le ortolani j'habitais au lac de lugano
et vous êtes une fille rangée
oui je peux dire c'est que vous avez
rencontrés à sanaa dimanche vous êtes
passé
vous avez gagné voilà alors en 4 alors
non il ya quand même un problème en 1900
je sais pas si c'est vrai vous à nous
dire
mais en 1997 vous auriez passé une nuit
dans un palace au cap d'antibes pour un
million de dollars avec un prince
saoudien
vrai ou pas bélisle a traduit mao c'est
sur mac cela tombait en panne
c'est brachetti nous écoutons n'a
maintenant vous êtes une base de la
demoiselle
gt gt chemin non non vous n'étiez pas
dans le palace parce qu'il paraît que le
mec il n'arrivait pas à se payer pamela
anderson
ils ont très bien rythmé pour un million
de dollars tu seras avec moi
mais la belle et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu